APART AND [BLEEP] KILL
YOURSELVES.
KILL YOURSELVES.
>> Laura: SENIOR REPORTER
JULIO ROSAS HAS BEEN ON THE
GROUND FOR DAYS COVERING THE
CHAOS IN SEATTLE AND JOINS US
NOW.
JULIO, THAT VIDEO IS SHOCKING,
BUT WHAT IS EVEN MORE SO IS A
COUNCILWOMAN WAS STANDING RIGHT
THERE AND SAID NOTHING.
>> YEAH, NO, EXACTLY.
THERE’S A LOT OF CRAZINESS GOING
ON RIGHT NOW.
FROM WHAT I’VE SEEN TODAY, THE
PEOPLE INSIDE THE AUTONOMOUS
ZONE ON CAPITOL HILL, THEY ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT TO DO
NEXT, BECAUSE NOW THEY’VE HELD
THIS SIX BLOCK RADIUS FOR A FEW
DAYS NOW, AND NOW THEY ARE JUST
GETTING TO ON WHAT THE NEXT
STAGE IN THEIR PLANS ARE, AND
SO, FIRST THIS MORNING, THINGS
WERE RELATIVELY CALM, BREAKING
OFF INTO GROUPS, TALKING ABOUT
DIFFERENT THINGS ON WHAT THE
NEXT STEPS ARE, BUT THINGS KIND
OF GOT A LITTLE TENSE WHEN SOME
SEATTLE POLICE OFFICERS CAME
INSIDE THE ZONE TO GO INSIDE THE
EAST PRECINCT AND GET THEMSELVES
OUT OF THEIR OFFICE.
AT THAT POINT, HALF OF THE CROWD
WANTED TO MAKE SURE NOTHING
HAPPENED TO THE OFFICERS, BUT
THE OTHER HALF OF THE CROWD WAS
ASKING, WELL, WHAT ARE THEY
DOING HERE?
THIS IS OUR ZONE, THIS IS OUR
TERRITORY, GOES AGAINST
EVERYTHING WE HAVE BEEN DOING
THE PAST FEW DAYS, AND THERE
WERE ARGUMENTS BREAKING ON
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD BE
LETTING THEM IN.
NOW, AS I POSTED ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, THERE IS BEEN A
LOT OF ARGUMENTS WITHIN THEIR
LITTLE TOWN HALL THAT THEY’VE
SET UP ON, AGAIN, WHAT THE NEXT
STEPS ARE, AND RIGHT NOW, THERE
IS NO CLEAR, DECISIVE LEADERSHIP
INSIDE, SO THINGS ARE REALLY
KIND OF DEGRADING INSIDE THE
ZONE.
>> Laura: THIS IS HOW CNN’S
OLIVER DARCY EXPLAINED WHAT IS
GOING ON IN SEATTLE FROM
3,000 MILES AWAY.
HE SAID "IF YOU BEEN GETTING
YOUR NEWS FROM RIGHT-WING MEDIA,
YOU PROBABLY THINK OUR MILITANT
ANTIFA ACTIVISTS HAVE SEIZED A
SECTION OF SEATTLE, BUT THE
MAYOR’S OFFICE TELLS ME CITY
OFFICIALS HAVE NOT INTERACTED
WITH ARMED ANTIFA MILITANTS AT
THIS SITE."
THIS VIDEO IS WHAT YOU SHOT FROM
INSIDE THIS ZONE LAST NIGHT.
[SIREN]
WEEP
>> DID HE DO IT, WHO KNOWS?
LEAP.
>> Laura: DOESN’T SEEM LIKE IT
WAS ALL PEACE AND LOVE THERE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED IT CNN
FAKE NEWS, THERE IS A REASON THE
INSULT STICKS.
A YOUNG MAN THAT WAS SURROUNDED
BY THE CROWD, HE WAS ACCUSED OF
STEALING, FROM WHAT I COULD
GATHER, HE WAS ACCUSED OF
STEALING A PHONE FROM ANOTHER
PROTESTER, SO THEY SAID HE WAS A
THIEF, AND HE WAS TRYING TO GET
AWAY, THEY’RE ASKING, WELL, IF
YOU’RE INNOCENT WHY ARE YOU
RUNNING AWAY FROM US?
THE MAN WAS CLEARLY TERRIFIED,
AND AT ONE POINT, THERE WAS A
GUY WITH A BASEBALL BAT, AND HE
SHOVED THE BASEBALL BAT IN THE
GUY’S FACE AND SAID I’M GOING TO
BEAT YOU UP.
FORTUNATELY FOR THAT YOUNG MAN,
HE WAS ABLE TO GET AWAY FROM THE
CROWD, AND IT WAS THEN
DISCOVERED THAT HE DIDN’T STEAL
THE PHONE, THE PHONE WAS
DISCOVERED AT ANOTHER SPOT.
YOU CAN IMAGINE, AT THE CROWD
DECIDED TO USE A BASEBALL BAT
AGAINST HIM, ONLY TO FIND OUT
THAT HE DIDN’T ACTUALLY STEAL
ANYTHING --
>> Laura: YEAH, THERE WERE
INDIVIDUALS --
>> A PRETTY INTENSE MOMENT.
>> Laura: THERE WERE
INDIVIDUALS WITH WEAPONS, RIGHT,
INSIDE THE "ZONE," BECAUSE WE’VE
SEEN THEM.
I GUESS CNN HAS TROUBLE DOING A